here's the controversial senior editor
or Breitbart news and author of the
upcoming book dangerous my lolly
innopolis yes happy to have you here
your very controversial I I don't know
why well we're gonna conquer don't know
one lovely yeah I know yeah well we'll
find that out I'm going to start with an
open mind because honestly I only heard
of you about a year ago you're all of
what 31 32 but thank you okay
27 officially okay you look like Bruno
you know he said he was 19 you know I
told her the doll down the contouring
she didn't listen your makeup lady was
just crying alright anyway so about a
year ago people started to tell me are
you gonna get this guy Milo you know on
your show and I tried to look into you
know what you're saying and look I think
your colossal II wrong on a number of
things but if exactly if I if I band
around from my real and who I thought
was colossal II wrong I would be talking
to myself what he wouldn't have you
wouldn't have an cool trauma to do my
Jack Kingston on whose other than one
okay so I have an open mind but so let's
start with the contradictions about you
which is pretty crazy because you're
you're gay and you're boiler alert oh
come on you can do better than that
what did you are I've been reading about
you I mean your mother's Jewish yeah but
you have a Black Muslim boyfriend no but
well now but you did feel black not
Muslim not my son but he was one of them
right there was somebody fun okay will
you slow yeah I talked about it we
spoken out against all these few people
like you say you don't hire gay people
oh no you can't trust me show up to work
on time pretty much drugs too much sex
they never show up to work always making
excuses no no no I mean only bad as
women but no I don't have you know
that's not I mean no they were you but
you know that's just kidding you're easy
you're very easy very easily triggered
it's pathetic that well let's get to
that I was I there's so many things I
could started arguing with you about but
but because I know gay people do show up
to work okay but yes but that is because
that is the reaction you are so um let's
say helped by the fact that liberals
just always take debate of course now
you're a conservative I'm a liberal I
said I don't know why I don't know if
I'm conservative I mean well you were
nari and I work this right Bart and
you're a trump supporter
well it's interesting work themselves
into thing that they radical gay
editorials you know saying interesting
provocative things about gays are now
being published by bright bar and I
don't think really that you can call
Trump a traditional conservative he's
not that Republican no you're correct
about that so I don't know if that very
well I care about race free speech and
free expression I want people to be able
to be are you and say anything in these
days you're right that's a conservative
I care about in the environment and
living also and but greasy
but I mean you're right I mean you know
we've both over the position now we have
both been a disbarred at Berkeley you
know I I when I gave the commencement at
eclis I just like to say I mean they
just they just disinvited you I had
riots people got people people got
beaten up you're right no you do
Laurentiis okay you win bird you fifteen
you beat me out there there were no
right it's not a competition and you
know it's not a competition but but like
when you make liberals crazy yet for
that part of liberalism that has gone
off the deep and most of it yeah well
under your the only good one no I
you're literally the only good up I am
sewing right has gone insane there
emma-crats to the party of Lena Dunham
these people are mental hideous people
are the more that America sees of Lena
Dunham the fewer you know crap are you
ever going to get this is the people
that pick on fellow HBO stars they're so
bright he was I was I know supposed to
do that no of course you didn't brief me
about that no I'm sorry we don't usual
because excuse me because we don't brief
here because it is free speech well I
like that I know I need a mission I'm
not it's another thing I love a be sugar
sure horrible but that's okay we
disagree no but these people used to be
funny before they contracted feminism is
like Sarah so and he was really really
funny when other someone I'm a fan of
let's get off this let's let's talk
about your humor because I think a lot
of people do miss your humor and I'm a
guy who always defends jokes yeah right
up to the point where they pointlessly
hurt people I think you've ever know I
hurt people
no I have my whole I really hurt people
for a reason but you know I like to
think of myself as a virtuous troll but
if it's if somebody gets hurt in the in
because of truth needs to be said well I
guess religion I've always attacked
religion well we're sound on Islam
unlike most of the people in your
tightly yes very good true but all
religion I always say is stupid and
dangerous that hurts that Catholicism
which is awesome but otherwise yet okay
well that shows you
and I hope when you look in the mirror
tonight I'm very happy with what I see
in the mirror I don't see Bruno and I'm
not talking about what you see I'm
talking what's in your head when you
recognize who are a Catholic I hope you
say to yourself gee I'm also capable of
[ __ ] stupid thinking well everyone's
capable of greece's okay all right
that's okay no it's a it's a it's a
characteristic of the modern left I
think requiring you know there's
absolute consistency and effect for
getting that people are messy and
complicated and forgetting also some
obvious other human truths I think some
realities of human psychology like for
instance is the reason they want to
police humor you know it is very
important to both of us is that they
can't control it because the one thing
authoritarianism out of laughter because
they can't control people find also
Biggers when people laugh they know it's
true yeah of course not and annoys
people or muted people like the truth
laughter is involuntary exactly when you
laugh even if you don't really agree in
that if I got your mind exactly so I get
my college talk you got the rioters at
the front who is there to kind of
monitor me to say make sure I don't off
the rail and I make a joke about Ted
Cruz or something and they're like you
think you can see it you can see it and
the other thing the other thing that's
really important not just not just that
but the other thing is you know humor
isn't how you drive people apart you
know these sort of policing humor for
racism and sexism is utterly wrongheaded
not just because normally it isn't there
but because that's how we build bridges
not how we break them you know when you
make a joke about when you make a joke
that's how you connect with somebody you
know you make jokes at the bar you're
awkward small talk humans have what
brings people together not will drive
from a pirate and it's basic you know
fundamental human psychological insight
the progressive not I mean one area
where I'm a little concerned is when you
go after people individually because
like I said I would if it's in the cause
of a greater truth I you know if if
people are hurt as you know collateral
damage I'll go there but like I didn't
understand like the Ghostbusters thing
first of all who gives a [ __ ] I read a
bad review of a museum I'm not entitled
to do that I think she looked like a
dude she does you know I said right so
try be her an illiterate she is and I
simply don't accept I do not accept that
a Hollywood you know that the star of a
Hollywood blockbuster that an a-list
mega celebrity is sitting in a Hollywood
mansion crying over me
on the internet get over it and if you
are over it which I suggest you about
which I suspect you are because it's not
really the case that she's sitting there
upset about me was on the Internet
actually she's been deployed by the
studio because the movies tanking you
know you've just got to accept I'm sorry
you've just got to accept me no as an
Internet Joe hurt anyway to see my
Twitter's were either ugly horrible
thing every Twitter feed is they know
they're not there we are
when I had a Twitter it was the funniest
thing in America very fabulous but you
know what actually hurts people is known
as that happen in the real world I mean
I don't go at it because I'm not a
professional ride but I do get syringes
through my door dead animals through my
door you say you get mean tweets that's
okay not a competition but um what
actually hurts people is like murder
violence you know that riot stuff mean
words doesn't have which some people
would say you have been cited what how
I'm just saying some people would so
they would be idiots well they would be
yeah no and I you know I agree with you
about the Twitter thing I mean I stopped
reading most of my Twitter feed a long
time ago because if I want to cry myself
to sleep every night I could just read
my Twitter feed no I know they like get
off on it I love it you know I give my
trolls mug that time you and your I'm a
little I'm a little broken
I gave you an offset of 10 a little
break now you did you're a little broken
and you're very wrong about certain
things I collect media like black lives
matter is a hate group and that there's
no such thing as white privilege I mean
you do know that that we're happy to sit
we know that we can disagree on those
things and that's wonderful the one
thing that should unite us the one thing
that we I think that you and I can both
agree on and the one thing that was so
remarkable when that I mean I've never
heard of him before that silly man who
had a hissy fit this week it refused to
come on the show it doesn't understand
is that yeah if you don't show up to
debate you lose right and if you don't
ask any ion and also stop taking the
bait liberals effect oh my goodness what
a minute ended in fish British bag
[Applause]
[Music]
it's so ridiculous right I only look if
I am you know if I'm any eye somebody
sent me this which is so funny because
they knew you're coming on now these are
some things Joan Rivers who by the way
when she died
Obama the liberal president that we all
love up commented they don't comment
when someone dies unless they're a
national treasure yes he said not only
did she make us laugh she made us think
here's what she said on Michelle Obama
Blackey oh you know Michelle is a [ __ ]
Robin Quivers [ __ ] you look like a
[ __ ] mudslide
I hate Houston is crawling with bugs
oh wait that's Whitney Houston you know
my favorite my favorite actly but that's
the person we find to be a national
treasure I'm just saying no line is kind
of blurred and some of its context you
know because somebody is perceived to
have conservative politics which I think
I've said it least questionable in my
case right I guess somebody's perceived
to have conservative politics there are
different rules you can't make jokes
over you doesn't get off the Trump train
because Oh Corrigan you're a guy who
loves free he'd be fabulous for a guy
who loves free speech you wanted a weird
no no no no he's not
again